el señor milman usted ha votado a favor
del acuerdo con el fmi porque
buenas noches a todos los televidentes
nosotros hemos votado toda nuestra
condición que es la posición de
oposición en la argentina porque primero
porque la constitución nacional le
establece que el congreso nacional se
ocupa de autorizar a los empréstitos las
deudas externas internas y arreglar la
deuda eso establece la constitución
nacional que es potestad el congreso no
así el programa de gobierno que lleve
adelante el poder ejecutivo que
justamente en nuestra constitución
nacional está en cabeza de la
administración general de gobierno en el
presidente de la nación y su jefe de
gabinete y en nosotros emprendimos que
la argentina no debía entrar en una
sensación de pagos con el fondo
monetario internacional que la argentina
debe honrar sus deudas entonces le dimos
la autorización al presidente para que
pueda negociar una el arreglo de la
deuda argentina por supuesto la manera
en que negoció las medidas que se tomen
son exclusiva responsabilidad de la
administración de los señores fernández
por tanto usted dice que las medidas son
exclusivas del gobierno pero que le
diría a las personas en argentina que
creen que este acuerdo traerá recortes
sociales
bueno en primer medida ya ha sido
sancionado hace escasos minutos por el
senado de la nación argentina la ley así
que falta en la rúbrica del presidente
de la nación para efectivamente ser
light esto acaba de ocurrir y lo que yo
quiero decir es que independientemente
de que el gobierno redujo si no vayan la
sensación de pago su lugar es donde son
los tres países en el mundo han llegado
y no han podido volver y las
consecuencias han sido devastadoras del
punto de vista social el acuerdo de
gestión que ha hecho el gobierno
argentino con el fondo monetario
internacional como le dije antes es
responsabilidad del presidente fernández
va a traer muchas dificultades a la
argentina va a traer dificultades en
aumentos de tarifas va a tener
dificultades en desabastecimiento de
productos de mayor inflación de falta de
energía de combustibles de luz de gas va
a tener consecuencias muy complejas para
la argentina va a tener un aumento en un
intento de aumento por parte del poder
ejecutivo sobre
todo lo que es el sector del campo que
es el sector más productivo de la
argentina la rueda con la cual argentina
consigue divisas para la argentina y lo
único que se le ocurre el gobierno es
quitarle recursos a este motor que
genera empleo genera producción genuina
y bueno y la verdad que es un sector que
también se va a perjudicar por las
políticas del gobierno así que
lamentablemente es el acuerdo que ha
llegado el gobierno de los fernández con
el fondo monetario internacional son de
políticas que va a sufrir el pueblo
argentino si igualmente este acuerdo
llega por una deuda que se contrajo en
2018 por un valor aproximado de 45 mil
millones de dólares en aquel momento su
coalición gobernaba el país bajo el
nombre de cambiemos había alternativa en
aquel momento la vía ahora
en aquel momento nosotros recurrimos al
fondo monetario internacional- en
realidad no con trajimos la deuda de la
argentina estaba endeudada con
el mercado privado de deuda porque la
argentina tiene un déficit fiscal y lo
que es puede entender cualquier familia
si gasta más de lo que ingresa lo tiene
que resolver de alguna manera le pide
prestado al vecino le pide prestado
a alguien y finalmente el expediente
estado al banco en este caso el banco se
expande monetario internacional- es el
banco de los países miembros entonces
primero en argentina recurrió para
cubrir el déficit que el gobierno de
cristina fernández de kirchner le dejó
al gobierno de mauricio macri recurrió
al mercado libre
privado y en un momento el mercado libre
privado se retiró de la posibilidad de
otorgar crédito a la argentina y eso
hizo que la única fuente que hubiera de
financiamiento fuera el fondo monetario
por lo tanto lo que hizo el gobierno de
mauricio macri fue ir al fondo para
pagar la deuda que nos dejó cristina